i grew up
in the family of skywriting
that's just a little kid that's all i
knew just like being an artist in the
sky
i'm greg stennis and i own a company
called sky typers with my son
steven stennis
[Music]
my dad was one of the original sky
writers he started in 1931.
the one airplane travels a big circle if
he's going to make an o and that takes a
lot of time to do that and
he decided hey there's got to be a
faster way to do this i'll just do it
with a bunch of airplanes
and so he came up with the method of sky
typing
five airplanes flying in formation
for instance if we're going to make an
eye everybody lets out just one puff
there's your eye if you want to turn
that into an l it's one puff plus the
bottom guy lets out three more puffs
there's your l
this is a very specialized form of
flying
most of my pilots have got you know like
10 000 flying hours so they're very
experienced
we fly aa-5b tiger planes
when we fly it's roughly
45 minutes to get up to altitude which
is 10 000 feet
a typical sky typing message is 20
characters sometimes 25
and that's roughly 5 miles length
each letter is the size of the empire
state building 1200 feet tall
they're the biggest ads in the world and
you can't miss them the whole sky
becomes your billboard
i do this because not only is it fun
because i love flying but i like the
the accomplishment of what we do because
the people we fly for they're all
thrilled
we've got something like 120 years of
skywriting
in the family
my dad trained me
and i've trained my son and i'm very
proud about the whole thing
you